lo que espero hacer en este vídeo es
aclarar unos términos que a lo mejor has
oído que se utilizan en temas
relacionados con todo lo que hemos visto
estos términos son gen
contra alelo
al hielo
y de eso vamos a hablar en este vídeo y
para eso movámonos al mundo del adn y
del a rn y digamos que esta línea
ondulada que tengo aquí es la longitud
de mi adn y bueno por aquí esta pequeña
sesión que tengo aquí le vamos a hacer
un acercamiento y veremos una secuencia
de pares de bases que recuerdan es la
información contenida en el adn aquí
sólo los dibuje como una escalera pero
sabemos que la verdadera forma del adn
es una escalera en forma de espiral es
una doble hélice ahora esta línea
ondulada que tenemos aquí puede ser una
sección de una línea más larga esto es
porque puede codificar para múltiples
cosas
especialmente múltiples proteínas
diferentes secciones de ella pueden
cuantificar para distintas proteínas por
ejemplo no sé se me ocurre pensar que
esta parte que tengo aquí donde está
esta sección esta parte que voy a
dibujar de color azul
toda esta codifica para una cierta
proteína así que toda esta parte
de mi adn codifica para una cierta
proteína en específico y a esto le
podemos llamar
este es un gen bueno puede codificar
para una proteína que está involucrada
no sé a algo se me ocurrirá no sé en el
sistema inmune una proteína que esté
involucrada en el sistema inmune y no
sea se me ocurre por acá puedes tener a
otro gen esté por acá lo voy a hacer un
poco más largo
va a ser todo este gen de aquí que va a
codificar para otra cosa no sé se me
ocurre que este otro tramo de adn a lo
mejor codifica para una proteína que
como ocurre que participa no sea en la
regulación de la replicación del adn y
bueno puedo tener otro por acá
imagínate esta pequeña parte de por aquí
esta pequeña parte de por aquí que bueno
sea otra sección del adn que codifica
para algo distinto no sé se me ocurre
que esta parte de ahí codifica para la
pigmentación de ojos o de piel entonces
estas secciones que tenemos aquí de adn
codifican para cosas específicas de
hecho no tienen que codificar solo
recordemos que si codifica para una
proteína bueno déjame ponerlo con este
color si codifica para una proteína lo
primero que vamos a hacer es pasar del
adn al a
n mensajero bueno de hecho primero vamos
a pasar a un pre a rn mensajero déjame
dibujar de aquí imaginarte que este va a
ser el rn mensajero
n mensajero y bueno recuerda que el pre
a rn mensajero pierde algunas partes
algunas secciones y bueno tenemos
después a este aire n mensajero y cada
tres pares de bases de este a rn
supongamos que aquí tenemos a tres
partes 1
3 a cada tres pares de bases se le
conoce como un codón
así que por aquí imagínate que tenemos a
otro cordón
imagínate que tengo una dos tres partes
y bueno cada uno de estos cordones va a
codificar para un aminoácido los cuales
bueno al unirse forman una proteína así
que por aquí puedo poner a un aminoácido
este sería uno de los aminoácidos y
bueno por equipo tener a otro de ellos
este sería otro de mis aminoácidos y
bueno si puedo seguir por aquí podría
tener a otro en mi camino ácidos y así
seguir y seguir y seguir
todos ellos están unidos y de hecho son
transportados hacia el adn mensajero por
un grupo funcional de rn por lo tanto
hay otras cosas distintas a las
proteínas que codifican el adn como se
me ocurre pensar en el rn de
transferencia
r m de transferencia el cual como ya
vimos en los vídeos anteriores este
nt se une con su cordón correspondiente
se une con su cordón correspondiente y
pone al aminoácido en su lugar y bueno
también podremos tener cosas como el rn
en nuevos o mal ribosomas que forma
parte de la estructura de los ribosomas
entonces a lo que voy con todo esto es
que el a rn no solamente funciona como
intermediario también puede tener un
papel estructural o funcional y de hecho
hay teorías de que la vida más primitiva
no era más que rn auto replicante y
bueno los sistemas se volvieron más y
más y más complicados y complejos hasta
que ahora llegamos a cosas como los
robles o los hipo
los hipopótamos y elefantes pero bueno
todo empezó con moléculas de adn auto
replicante bueno otros dicen que lo
mejor era en proteínas auto replicantes
quién sabe pero el rn es definitivamente
un personaje importante en todo esto así
que tengo en cuenta entonces vamos del
gen al rn lo que se conoce como
transcripción o del rn a la proteína
este de aquí es una pro
y la del rn a la proteína lo que es la
traducción pero a veces te detienes en
el adn que por sí solo ya tiene una
función este sería el adn funcional pero
bueno cada uno de estos genes codifica
para algún tipo de proteína o un arnés
funcional y eso es justo lo que es un
gen una secuencia que codifica algo pero
entonces que es un alelo un alelo una
variante específica del gen por ejemplo
digamos que vemos la misma sección de tu
adn y del mío vamos a ponerlo aquí este
de aquí va a ser mi parte de mi adn y
ahora con otro color voy a tomar el
estudio y voy a suponer que este de aquí
va a ser tu adn y digamos que vemos el
mismo cromosoma en la misma región de
nuestro adn los dos somos humanos y
nuestro adn es muy similar así que
imagínate que me tomo
este gel de azul en nuestros adn es
el día de lsb así va a ser esta parte de
aquí y en el tuyo va a ser esta parte de
aquí te parece aunque nuestro adn es muy
similar puede haber variaciones en cómo
está codificado el gen por ejemplo yo
puedo tener justo aquí no sé se me
ocurre una adenina en este lugar tengo
una venida y tú puedes tener no sé una
base distinta tú puedes tener a no sé se
me ocurre una timina una timina justo en
el mismo lugar este gen codifica una
proteína oa una rn funcional que tiene
el mismo papel a lo mejor en el sistema
inmune como habíamos visto o en tu color
de piel o en el desarrollo del cerebro
ahora bien algunas de estas variaciones
que pueden surgir a partir de mutaciones
por ejemplo pueden no tener ningún
impacto en la función de la proteína que
será construida tú puedes tener un
aminoácido distinto algunas veces o
incluso tener el mismo menos ácido
porque tienes cordones que codifican
para un mismo aminoácido
pero aunque tuvieras un aminoácido
distinto en una proteína con 4000
aminoácidos bueno esto no cambia cómo
actúa la proteína o cómo funciona o
puede que sí puede que cambio su función
que cambie como regula a otras cosas y
quién sabe qué cambia algo más entonces
puedes imaginarte que este gen puede
tener un rol en el color de los ojos por
ejemplo y debido a esta variación u
otras variaciones que son expresadas y
aunque ambos codifican para la proteína
que determina el color de los ojos o
regula la cantidad de pigmento que
tienes puede ser que esta pequeña
variación participe para tener ojos
color azul y en verdad esto es muy
complejo es muy poco probable que tengas
un gen que haga esto pero puede ser que
la variación de tu quien participe para
tenerlos en los ojos azules déjame
ponerlo aquí
azules mientras que miguel esté
participe para tener los ojos cafés
y obviamente quiero pensar qué variante
obtuve de mi madre y qué variante obtuve
de mi padre todos tenemos dos copias del
mismo cromosoma en nuestras células
somáticas con excepción de los
cromosomas sexuales de todos los demás
cromosomas tenemos dos copias y por lo
tanto tenemos dos copias del mismo gen
solo son variantes distintas una
variante de la madre y otra variante del
padre podemos decir que son alelos
distintos entonces los alelos son sordos
distintas variantes
estos son diferentes alelos pero están
en el mismo gen que participa en el
color de los ojos pero son distintas
variaciones del mismo gen entonces
cuando hablamos de gen nos referimos a
una región del adn que codifica para no
ser una molécula funcional usualmente
una proteína pero recuerda que también
puede ser una rn mientras que con alé
y estamos hablando de una variación
específica es decir de del sabor de los
genes en fin espero que esto te haya
ayudado